when you show clips in your classes of
classic films which resonate most with
today's generation the Millennials like
when you show them which which are the
ones they have the most questions about
or they are that are most polarizing to
them you know what's really interesting
the things that really speak to them or
the things which have always spoken to
people that in that respect I don't
think there's that many differences
between Millennials I showed for example
in more Bergman's wild strawberries a
few weeks ago and they were blown away
they loved it they were so enthralled by
that film and the revelation at the end
of that movie when the old man lies in
bed and for the first time in that film
sees together his father and mother by
the reflecting pool at the end of the
film and you have this kind of a Jungian
vision of wholeness and completeness and
so on I don't care they're 18 19
whatever it was that spoke to them so i
would say that things that speak to
people today are the things that have
always spoken to them they are moments
which should heal in human emotions and
a kind of mythic truth all the
razzmatazz in the world finally doesn't
speak to people as deeply as moments and
film which are genuinely human revealing
some human person working through
something that is what still speaks to
my film students when you talk about
temperament of the filmmaker and I know
Ingmar Bergman has been you know you see
fought sand demons of his own he was
very complex man but also very deep I
believe in so it's reflected in his
films do you talk about the filmmakers
and they're either the light films and
their light to enter absolutely and
there's one thing that Birdman said
which I always tell my film students
because it seems to me the heart of the
film making business in the heart of
movies all together and it's all about
if you're Birdman points out that when
you watch a tomb our movie you're
actually watching a much shorter film
because what's going on is that since
the image is intermittent
light dark light dark light dark light
dark um there are in essence two
projectors always at work because the
mechanical one or the digital one and
then there's this one right here behind
your pineal gland and you are
co-creating the film that you're
watching and it's kind of inherent in
nature of movies themselves so um
Bergman's sort of movies Express I think
that understanding that there's
something mythic and deep about any
movie but particularly is so that's why
I personally feel a Bergman fantastic
and honestly it's the great the great
guys in Fellini Bergman my students
still love that and what thrills me is
that I show them a movie like La Strada
and they never heard of it never seen it
and still love it
you